jennifer lopez and ben affleck are
packing on the pda during their italian
honeymoon it's just a dream come true
check out the love birds walking the
streets of milan for a day of shopping
the singers rocking a white crop top
white jeans and platform heels
completing the look with the fedora and
then he kept it simple sporting a blue
long sleeve shirt jeans and sneakers at
one point inside a boutique the two
couldn't keep their hands off each other
yeah jen's holding tight to her man with
the biggest smile on her face talk about
post-nuptial bliss we're super happy
what can i tell you we're just having a
good time and good times were had just
days before at benifer's wedding
extravaganza at the actor's 83-acre
estate in georgia
for the lavish second ceremony for the
couple all guests were white including
kevin smith who spilled all the wedding
details to e.t it's absolutely beautiful
you know she's got impeccable taste so
the whole wedding looks fantastic
beautifully appointed flawless
but he's never been happier i've seen
that dude be happy but the pure joy that
was like radiating from his face
is was absolutely unforgettable is
honestly one of the like 10 sweetest
uh
precious most precious moments i've ever
witnessed in my life and it wasn't even
mine
uh
i was happy for him man they were happy
you could tell like they worked hard to
get here they earned it oh and you know
j.lo brought the fashion to her big day
i always have fun with fashion the merry
me star donned not one but three unique
wedding gowns courtesy of ralph lauren
[Music]
the event ended up being exactly what
the two wanted a source telling e.t jen
and ben were elated the entire weekend
quote married life is still fresh of
course but jen and ben are so excited to
have formally shared this bonding
experience with their closest friends
and family it's exciting it's exciting
and bedford 2.0 is so ready for what's
to come they are just so thrilled to
spend the rest of their lives together
they have an unbreakable bond they
realize that could sound corny but they
truly and authentically feel like they
were destined to be together
[Music]